là les témoignages surtout sont des gens
avec qui mais le connaissais pas une en
prison la journaliste littéraire n'a
recevez un jeune histoire
les témoignages qu'on a à vous le voyez
dans le monde sont des témoignages de
personnes voile avec qui il ya eu des
malades et des entretiens d'embauché des
rencontres voilà c'était ça n'a rien à
voir
willy bernard continent ce que je veux
dire c'est le patineur à avoir on le
sait a tf1 on se bousculer au portillon
les fermes se bousculent au portillon
pour le rencontrer pour lui parler et
voir plus que ces mêmes chez lui devant
chez lui tout ça moi c'est un ami fidèle
je le dis clairement sa demi-finale que
j'aime beaucoup c'est bien de le dire
c'est un homme qui aime conquérir en
aucun cas il ne fait appel à la violence
moi ça fait trente ans que je le connais
donc je peux le dire j'ai jamais vu ça
j'ai vu beaucoup de conquêtes évidemment
et par la discrétion je vais pas dire
qu'ils les gens qu'on connaît
il a multiplié les conquêtes ils adorent
ça mais en aucun cas il n'est lié ni à
la violence et encore moins à la force
c'est ça je tiendrais dans quel état
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai il avait
invité aujourd'hui j'ai changé avec lui
paraissait mais il m'a dit voilà qu'il
était mais voilà qui n'était pas en état
de devenir très triste
il est très triste on peut comprendre il
est très triste voilà parce que je les
appelais ce matin parce qu'on souhaitait
le recevoir
et il dit qu'il vous aime beaucoup et
c'est qu'ils apprécient les missions et
cetera que ceci ne fera rien il va juste
va envoyer un communiqué afp c'est tout
ce qu'il fera pas telle est rien il est
très triste il est abattu
évidemment que l'état battu il y aura
des faux qu'un qui vont se perdre et
tout en respectant parfaitement la
présomption d'innocence je vais revenir
sur ce que vous disiez cissé lors
d'entretiens d'embauché s'il ya une
position hiérarchique sa porte un nom
juridique ces abus de position dominante
et c'est ce qui lui est reproché
notamment dans le monde et si c'était
vrai c'est une circonstance aggravante
c'est à dire que ça maintient sous
dépendance les femmes et les jeunes
femmes qui auraient pu subir les
violences voire et autoroutes ont une
fois encore chaud pendant en train de
faire le procès d'un homme dans les
médias là il ya eu un nouveau témoignage
en a cinq qui sont anonymes alors ça
vaut pas rien mais c'est quand même
moins concret que des témoignages à
visage découvert
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
juridiquement juridiquement dans
l'aujourd'hui tjb denjean société mais
les silos saisir si je veux témoigner de
manière anonyme et que je veux dire qu
untel ou unetelle m'a violée etc
on peut le faire donc je ne dis pas que
ces voiles arriverait voyages en ligne
ce sont des témoignages anonymes
ensuite et ceux qui l'accusent mais à
ceux qui le défendent aussi claire
chazal son ex compagne jean pierre
pernaut sa fille morgane et une de ses
deux secrétaires dans le papier du monde
qui pourtant le profil type des victimes
qu'il affectionnait ou qu'il affectionne
ray donc pour moi voilà je pense qu'il
faut aussi dire que des gens qu'ils
défendent et je pense qu'il ne faut pas
juger la faire à la place de la justice
qui a justement une justice pour ça il
faut laisser l'enquêté se dérouler et
c'est bon on a compris qu'ils avaient
des plaintes maintenant on a compris
qu'il ya des témoignages maintenant
c'est à la justice de dori le staff et
un café